c'est une très triste nouvelle comme
thomas pris cette nouvelle lire j'ai été
terrassé même le sachant malade mais on
a toujours espoir quand vous avez passé
comme vous dites j'ai passé 22 ans de ma
vie à chanter à côté de lui un
partenaire exemplaire
jamais un mot qui fois se nomme sage
excellents musiciens talentueux bon
voilà malheureusement la vie a décidé
autrement
donc tous lors qu'elles soient aumônier
vraiment affecté nous sommes attristés
on a toujours pensé que je vous même
s'il ne revenait pas avec nous dans
leurs caisses mais qu'il serait là au
moins où jusqu'à en bonne santé qu'est
ce qu'elle a au moins pouvoir le suivi
de ce que et loquace harmonie
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
donc voilà on est forcé de constater on
obligé d'accepter mais c'est pas facile
il y sera aussi
oui ah oui à ça ça parce que quand on
parle de d'harmonie souvent disait enfin
une anecdote un pour les deux chanteurs
on disait fait blanc et puis peut-être
nous et ça veut dire comment j'ai les
cheveux noirs ils lui avaient cheveux
grisonnants et mamies les gens qui
pensaient des fois que nous étions frère
parce qu'on soit dit bon vous avez
nouveau centre vous à une complicité
je dis oui non c'est pas mon frère si tu
veux bon on est frères de musique web et
ah oui ça va laisser une ampoule est
même s'il n'est pas là on va toujours
pour saluer parce qu'il ya des morceaux
qu'il a chanté et justement qu'on a pas
au volontaire mois par voit sa mémoire
n'a pas voulu toucher parce que c'était
lui
c'était sa façon de faire c'était son
empreinte c'était savoir donc on a
préféré laisser ça comme ça de côté
je pense que ça va rester toujours aidé
les bulls est cette marque là et puis il
avait une particularité c'est qu'il
ça va monter dans les aigus les revélois
de tête c'était sont approuvés il avait
une voix très haut perché pour les aigus
c'était souvent lui importe on faisait
les coeurs les voies en l'air voir les
monsois alors qu'ils montaient dans les
aigus c'était son truc
donc voilà c'était sans qualité c'était
ça c'était saluant les morceaux de salsa
il excellait là dedans et puis surtout
l'écart des taux de change les boléros
ça c'était ça les volets où les tango
ça c'était sans tirer à lui en ce sens
domaine il accélère la dent